TOWERS FOUNDATION.
GREG GUTFELD TAKES IT ALL FROM
HERE.
>> GUTFELD: YES, HAPPY TUESDAY,
EVERYONE.
GREAT TO SEE JOE MACKEY IS ON
TODAY.
I WONDER WHAT HE'S BEEN UP TO.
(ENGINE REVVING).
>> GUTFELD: I HAD NO IDEA YOU
WERE SUCH A THRILL-SEEKER.
NO?
>> NO, NOT REALLY.
>> GUTFELD: WELL, THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
SO, IT'S NO LONGER A BORDER
CRISIS, IT'S AN UNMITIGATED
BORDER DISASTER MEGACRISIS.
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS LIVING
UNDER A TEXAS BRIDGE, AND NOT IN
A GOOD WAY.
YOU KNOW, IF THIS WERE SPRING
BREAK AND THOSE WERE PARTYING
UNDERGRADS, THE OUTRAGE WOULD BE
PALPABLE.
IT'S A SUPER SPREADER EVENT,
WHERE ARE THE MASKS?
WHY AREN'T THEY SIX FEET APART.
WHAT DO THEY THINK THIS IS, THE
EMMYS?
WHICH RAISES THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION, HOW DID IT GET THIS
BAD.
IT'S SIMPLE, THE MEDIA DOES ITS
BEST NOT TO COVER BAD NEWS FOR
THEIR GUYS IN OFFICE OR IN
DELAWARE OR WHEREVER JOE'S
WANDERED OFF TO IN AN OPEN ROBE,
HIS HANDS STICKY FROM ROCKY
ROAD.
REMEMBER, IT'S NOT WHAT THEY
REPORT ON, IT'S WHAT THEY OMIT
THAT DOES THE DAMAGE.
THE MEDIA HOLDS THE REINS.
YES, THE REIN, WE'LL GET TO
THAT.
FOX COVERED THE BORDER UNDER
BOTH TRUMP AND BIDEN.
AND THE FACT IS WE'D ALL BE LIKE
BIDEN AND HARRIS, TOTALLY
CLUELESS IF NOT FOR FOX NEWS'
AMAZING COVERAGE. IF TRUMP WERE
IN CHARGE, ALL OF THE NETWORKS
WOULD COVER IT LIKE THE KENNEDY
ASSASSINATIONS, THEY WOULD PAT
THEMSELVES ON THE BACK WITH ONE
HAND AND DOING GOD KNOWS WHAT
ELSE WITH THE OTHER.
INSTEAD THEY BURY IT LIKE THEY
DO WITH HIS PREVAGEN SCONE. MORE
THAN 12,000 MIGRANTS ARE PACKED
IN A REFUGEE CAMP -- IN AMERICA,
THE CAMP.
REMEMBER HOW THE MEDIA PREDICTED
DONALD TRUMP WAS GOING TO PUT
PEOPLE IN CAMPS?
THEY GOT THE CAMPS PART RIGHT
BUT THEY TOOK THEM TO ELECT
BIDEN SO THEY COULD GET THE CAMP
LIKE THE FAMOUS REPUBLICAN
TYRANT, FDR.
AND THE MEDIA?
THEY'RE AS QUIET AS JOE IN HIS
1:00 P.M. NAP.
IN CASE YOU WONDERED IF THERE
WAS A WAY FOR THE MEDIA CAN CARE
ABOUT THE BORDER, THERE IS.
YOU FLIP IT SO THE AMERICANS ARE
THE MONSTERS THEN THEIR HEADS
TURN SO FAST.
THEN OUT COMES THE STORY THAT
THE BORDER PATROL WERE WHIPPING
HAITIANS COMING IN TO THE
COUNTRY.
AMERICANS WERE WHIPPING BLACK
PEOPLE AGAIN, JUST LIKE THE OLD
DAYS WHEN DEMOCRATS WERE IN
CHARGE. SO THE MEDIA IS NOW ALL
OVER THE STORY, SPREADING THIS
UNCHECKED MANURE LIKE A
PROFESSIONAL LANDSCAPER.
THEY KNOW IF THE STORY COULD BE
WIELDED AS A WEAPON AGAINST
AMERICA, THEY'D DO IT WHETHER
IT'S TRUE OR NOT.
WHEN IT COMES TO HATING
AMERICAN, THE TALIBAN HAS
NOTHING ON THESE CLOWNS. THE
BORDER PATROL CHIEF EXPLAINS,
THOSE AREN'T WHIPS BUT REIGNS TO
CONTROL THE HORSES.
WHICH MAKES SENSE, IT PROTECTS
THE HORSES AND THE PEOPLE
CLOSEST TO THEM.
DON'T TELL THAT TO THE MEDIA
THAT ONLY REACTED TO IMAGES WHO
ENFLAME THEM.
WHO NEEDS CONTEXT WHEN YOU HAVE
ONE INFLAMMATORY MOMENT.
THIS IS A PICTURE OF BORDER
PATROL ON A HORSE IN A STREAM.
SO HOW LONG BEFORE CNN ACCUSES
BORDER PATROLMEN OF TRYING TO
DROWN HORSES IN THE RIO GRANDE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S BEEN A WHILE SINCE I RODE A
HORSE, KENTUCKY DERBY, 2004.
I CAME IN EIGHTH. TURNS OUT, YOU
HAVE TO BE ON TOP OF THE HORSE.
BUT EVEN I KNEW THIS STORY WAS
KIND OF ODD.
MICKIE ALCINDOR OR PBS DESCRIBED
THE BORDER PATROL OF USING WHIPS
BEFORE ASKING JEN PSAKI THAT
THEY SHOULD BE FIRED SEEMINGLY,
JUST THAT THEY ARE SEEMINGLY A
NEWS ORGANIZATION, JUST BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THREE LETTERS IN THEIR
NAME, EVEN IF THE LETTERS STAND
FOR PURE [ BLEEP ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
IT WILL BE BLEEPED AT HOME, BUT
YOU CAN FIGURE OUT WHAT THE BS
STANDS FOR.
BUT THE SUFFERING OF 10,000
REFUGEES DIDN'T MATTER UNTIL SHE
FOUND SOMEONE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SMEAR.
>> ALL GOOD QUESTIONS.
WE JUST SAW THIS FOOTAGE.
IT'S HORRIBLE TO WATCH.
I JUST HAVE TO GETTING MORE
INFORMATION ON IT.
AGAIN, APRIL, I DON'T HAVE MORE
I HAVE ALSO SEEN THE VIDEO.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT THE
SCENARIO IS WHERE THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE.
>> OH, I CAN IMAGINE THE
SCENARIO.
BUT ENOUGH ABOUT MY GOLDEN GIRLS
FANTASY.
IN IT, I'M TIED UP AND EACH ONE
HAS A RIDING CROP.
MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE JUST STOPPED
WITH "I HAVE A FANTASY."
REMEMBER THE GOOD OLE DAYS WHEN
REPORTERS ACTUALLY USED THEIR
BRAINS AND FEET AND RAN DOWN A
STORY.
NEITHER DO I.
THEY JUST SEE SOMETHING ON-LINE
AND THAT'S THEIR SOURCE.
IT'S A COMMON THING, IGNORE A
BIG STORY BECAUSE THOSE IMAGES
UNDERMINE YOUR POLITICAL SIDE.
BUT EMBRACE ONE IMAGE BECAUSE
THEY CAN THEN FRAME IT ANY WAY
THEY WANT.
SO, RUN WITH THE IMAGE, ASK
QUESTIONS LATER, CALL IT
COVINGTON 101.
ALL RIGHT, PEOPLE, WE'RE
JOURNALISTS.
WE'VE REACHED OUR CONCLUSIONS.
LET'S GO FIND SOME EVIDENCE.
>> I FOUND SOME SHOCKING PHOTOS
AND I CHECKED ALL OF OUR
SOURCES.
INSTAGRAM AND TIKTOK.
>> NOT GOING TO DO, DOUBLE CHECK
TWITTER TOO.
>> GOTCHA.
HERE'S WHAT I FOUND, A LADY
YELLING AT A CAT.
PRESUMABLY ABOUT THE WAGE GAP.
>> OH, NOT BAD.
MAKE SURE THE CAT IDENTIFIES AS
A CAT.
>> THEN THERE'S THIS.
THIS IS AN ELDER WILL IMAN.
HE'S COLD AND ALONE.
A WAR HERO, MAYBE VIETNAM VET.
>> VERY GOOD.
LOOKS HOMELESS WITH THAT HAIR
CUT, CERTAINLY NOT SOMEONE WHO
OWNS MULTIPLE HOMES.
>> AND THIS ONE, A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE UNDER A BRIDGE?
>> NO, THAT'S NOT NEWS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> UNTIL THIS WHIP STORY SNAGGED
ABC WHO PRIOR TO THIS DIDN'T
GIVE A CRAP ABOUT THE BORDER
CRISIS.
>> THERE ARE ALARMING IMAGES
FROM THE TEXAS BORDER TONIGHT.
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESSED ON THEM
TODAY CALLING THE IMAGES
HORRIFIC.
WHAT WERE SOME BORDER PATROL
AGENTS DOING?
>> LOOK AT WHAT THESE AGENTS ARE
DOING. YEAH, IT'S CALLED THEIR
JOB, YOU SHOULD TRY IT SOMETIME.
TURNS OUT -- TURNS OUT, HE'S AS
SHALLOW AS A SUPERMODEL IN A
KIDDIE POOL.
BUT HE IS HANDSOME.
AND FINALLY THE SECOND DUMBEST
MAN ON CNN -- I'LL LET YOU
FIGURE OUT THE FIRST, GOES ALL
IN WITH THE SLAVERY ANALOGY.
>> WE REALLY ARE IN THE THROES
IN THIS COUNTRY OF FIGURING OUT
WHO WE ARE AND WHAT WE'RE ABOUT.
AND I WAS TAKEN ABACK.
BY -- BY A SINGLE IMAGE.
THAT SHOULD MAKE YOU PAY
ATTENTION TO A PROBLEM.
THE IMAGE -- TO ME IT DOES SMACK
OF A BYGONE ERA OF SLAVERY,
AIDED BY REPORTS OF PEOPLE BEING
BEATEN WITH A RIDING CROP OR THE
REINS, MOST LIKELY. YOU MAY BE
DRAWN TO THE DESPERATION OF THE
MAN TRYING TO ESCAPE.
OTHERS, IN THE DESPERATION OF
KEEPING OUR BORDERS SAFE.
OF WHAT I BELIEVE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRIED TO DEPICT AS A
BROWN MENACE AT OUR BORDER. NONE
OF THIS, NONE OF IT, IS NEW. AND
IT IS NOT ISOLATED.
>> YES, NONE OF THIS IS NEW IF
YOU MEAN THE HOT GARBAGE SPEWING
FORTH FROM YOUR GAPING LYING PIE
HOLE. AND I DON'T BLAME -- I
DON'T BLAME THIS JACKASS FOR NOT
COVERING THE BORDER.
HE WAS TOO BUSY DEFENDING HIS
CORRUPT BROTHER AND TRYING TO
SAVE HIS JOB ON A NETWORK HOOKED
UP TO A RESPIRATOR IN GRAVE
CONDITION.
DON'T LET HIS BROTHER NEAR THE
NETWORK.
SO, INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON
THE THOUSANDS OF HAITIANS LIVING
UNDER A BRIDGE, CHRIS GRASS
TELLS HIM ONE OUTRAGEOUS IMAGE
LIKE IT'S A PLASTIC DUMBBELL,
AND I DON'T MEAN DON LEMON.
I GUESS WE SHOULD BE GRATEFUL
FOR A LIBERAL MEDIA PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE CRISIS THEY
HELPED TO CREATE BY GETTING
BIDEN ELECTED.
NOTHING TO DO WITH COMPASSION OR
JOURNALISM.
THEY FOUND THE WAY DO THE STORY
SO IT'S NOT ABOUT THE WHITE
HOUSE BUT INSTEAD EVIL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S ABOUT AMERICANS TRYING TO
DO THEIR JOB BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE MEDIA
WON'T DO THEIRS.
NOW YOU WATCH THE HACKS IN
GOVERNMENT SUDDENLY CHANGING
THEIR TUNE.
>> IMAGES HAVE COME OUT OF
BORDER PATROL AGENTS WHIPPING
HAITIAN IMMIGRANTS.
MY QUESTION IS DO YOU THINK
THAT'S A HUMANE WAY TO TREAT
MIGRANTS.
>> YOU ARE ASSUMING FACTS NOT
YET DETERMINED.
TO ENSURE THE CONTROL OF THE
HORSE, LONG REINS ARE USED BUT
WE WILL INVESTIGATE THE FACTS TO
ENSURE THAT THE SITUATION IS AS
WE UNDERSTAND IT TO BE.
AND IF IT'S ANYTHING DIFFERENT,
WE WILL RESPOND ACCORDINGLY.
>> ANY MISTREATMENT OR ABUSE OF
A MIGRANT IS UNACCEPTABLE, IS
AGAINST BORDER PATROL POLICY.
>> ONE IMAGE. SO, YOU SEE MY
POINT?
IT WOULD BE ONE THING IF THE
PRESS OR MAYORKAS HAD CARED
ABOUT THE CRISIS WHILE WE CARED
ABOUT THE CRISIS.
ALL OF THAT FOOTAGE WE SHOWED?
YOU KNOW IF THEY FOLLOWED THIS
STORY AND THE GOVERNMENT HAD
ACTED, WE WOULDN'T EVEN BE
DISCUSSING THIS STORY BECAUSE IT
WOULDN'T EXIST.
FACT IS, THIS IS JUST ABOUT
SEIZING THE STORY THAT SUITS
THEM. THAT HAVE FOUND A BOO
GEEMAN, A COP ON A HORSE.
THEY PRETEND TO CARE WHEN THEY
DON'T GIVE A DAMN AT ALL.
LET'S WAKE UP TONIGHT'S
GUEST.
HE KNOWS WHERE HIS LAST TOP IS.
THE PHILANTHROPIST AND EXECUTIVE
VP OF THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION,
ERIC TRUMP.
SHE'S SO BRIGHT, TOO HUNG OF TO
LISTEN TO HER.
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK, NO ONE WILL
MISS HER, CAT ROSENFIELD.
HE'S THE MAN OF A THOUSAND FACES
AND ALL OF THEM TERRIFYING,
COMEDIAN JOE MACKEY.
AND, OPPOSITES ATTRACT IS A NICE
WAY OF SAYING HER HUSBAND NEVER
SAYING HER HUSBAND NEVER BURNED
DOWN A REFORM SCHOOL.
ERING, TO THE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS, HOW ARE MY SOCK
CHOICES TODAY?
>> ILL LIKE YOUR SOCKS.
>> I GOT ELEPHANTS ON MY SOCKS.
>> YEAH, IT'S NICE.
I CAN SEE THE ELEPHANTS.
MINE ARE STRIPY AND DOTTY.
I FEEL A LITTLE WEIRD WEARING
THEM.
I THOUGHT I WOULD GET THAT OUT
OF THE WAY.
YOU WERE STARING AT ME WONDERING
WHAT THE HELL WAS WRONG WITH
THIS PERSON.
>> A LITTLE BIT.
>> GUTFELD: THAT'S OKAY.
WHY DID THE MEDIA IGNORE IT
UNTIL NOW.
>> HORRIBLE.
THE HYPOCRISY IS INSANE.
LAST WEEK, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DRONED A FAMILY
OF TEN.
THEY TOOK A HELL FIRE MISSILE
AND SHOT IT AT A FAMILY AND LIED
ABOUT IT.
BUT THEY WANT TO DEMONIZE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO'S RIDING A
HORSE.
WE KNOW THAT STORY.
BUT A FAMILY INCLUDING SEVEN
CHILDREN AND THEY THROW LAW
ENFORCEMENT UNDER THE BOAT
LITERALLY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
CONTROL A PROBLEM THAT THEY
CREATED?
AMAZING TO ME, CAT NO. 1, YOU'LL
BE CAT NO. 2.
>> CAN'T GETTING ANY BACK TOP
FROM YOU ANYMORE. SERIOUSLY.
HE HAS HER OWN PHONE.
SHE HAS CAR PRIVILEGES.
AND, YES, SHE'S CONSTANTLY HERE
COMPLAINING.
>> TOO MUCH ADVANCED NOTICE FOR
THE CAR, THOUGH.
I LIKE TO LIVE A LITTLE MORE
FREE SPIRITED THAN THAT.
>> YOU DON'T DRIVE THE CAR.
>> NOT WELL.
>> CAT ONE, I APOLOGIZE FOR CAT
TWO. THIS CHRIS CUOMO THING
DRIVES ME CRAZY.
YOU HAVE MONTHS AND MONTHS OF
ALL OF THE DISTURBING IMAGES ON
THE BORDER.
ALL I NEED IS ONE TO MAKE THE
WHOLE STORY AS HE DENIED
EVERYTHING ELSE.
WHY DO YOU THINK -- HOW CAN HE
NOT SEE THIS BLIND SPOT.
>> THIS IS A THING -- THIS IS A
PROBLEM WITH HOW NEWS IS
REPORTED ACROSS THE BORDER. THE
TRIBAL NARRATIVE, AMERICANS ARE
TOO STUPID TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
AT THE BORDER UNLESS THERE'S A
VILLAIN THEY CAN HATE.
IT MAKES ME CRAZY, I WOULD LIKE
FOR THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REPORTING THIS INFORMATION, TO
STICK WITH THE TRUTH.
THE TRUTH IS HORRIFYING ENOUGH.
IT'S UPSETTING.
WE COULD USE THE TRUTH.
>> WE COULD USE THE TRUTH, JOE.
I SAY THAT TO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING IN THE
MORNING.
>> I SPIN YARN, YOU KNOW THAT.
>> GUTFELD: YEAH, YOU DO AND YOU
MAKE A MEAN SWEATER.
ANY THOUGHTS ACROSS YOUR STRANGE
AND TWISTED MIND?
ARE REPORTERS LAZY OR IS IT
BIOLOGICAL THEY SEE AN IMAGE AND
RUN WITH IT AND THEY'RE TAUGHT
ABOUT CONTEXT BUT THEY FORGET IT
IF IT FULFILLS THEIR COGNITIVE
BIAS.
>> IT FITS THE NARRATIVE.
I WAS GOING TO MENTION THE DRONE
STRIKE AND HOW THEY IGNORED THAT
NARRATIVE AFTER THE FACT.
BUT ERIC BEAT ME TO THE PUNCH.
I WAS GOING TO TALK ABOUT HOW
THIS PROBLEM HAS BEEN IGNORED BY
THE MEDIA FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
EVERY TIME I HEAR THE ESTIMATE
OF HOW MANY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE IN THE COUNTRY ITS, 11
MILLION OR 22 MILLION.
IT DOESN'T INSPIRE CONFIDENCE
WHEN THE GAP IS 11 MILLION
PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THAT MEANS YOU CAN
DEPORT, THEORETICALLY, 11
MILLION PEOPLE AND THERE WOULD
EITHER BE 0 PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, OR 11 MILLION
PEOPLE. I'M SORRY, I'M ALL
MESSED UP FROM THE JET SKI.
>> GUTFELD: AMAZING.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN DOING
THAT?
>> SIX OR SEVEN DAYS.
>> GUTFELD: YOU LOOK LIKE YOUF
BEEN DOING IT FOR YEARS.
>> I'M A GOOD ATHLETE.
>> GUTFELD: I'VE BEEN WATCHING
THAT ON LOOP IN THE HOT TUB.
CAT TWO, ANY FINAL THOUGHTS ON
THIS VERY INTERESTING STORY.
>> YEAH, I DID HAVE A THOUGHT.
I HAVEN'T HEARD IT ANYWHERE ELSE
OR SAID IT ANYWHERE ELSE, SO WHY
NOT TRY IT OUT ON THE SHOW THAT
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WATCH.
I WAS LOOKING AT THIS.
OBVIOUSLY, WE ONLY TALK ABOUT
THIS WHEN THERE IS A CRISIS AND
CONGRESS SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS, THIS IS
THEIR JOB.
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN IN A SYSTEM
THAT'S NOT TOTALLY MESSED UP.
I DID HAVE A THOUGHT ALSO.
>> GUTFELD: I THOUGHT THAT WAS
THE THOUGHT.
YOU LIED.
>> TWO THOUGHTS.
THIS THOUGHT IS DO ANY OF THESE
PEOPL
PEOPLE -- DO THEY WANT JOBS?
WE HAVE SO MANY OPEN JOBS.
THERE'S SO MANY JOB OPENINGS,
THEY WANT TO TAKE THEM.
BUT JESSICA FROM NEW JERSEY IS
TOO GOOD TO WORK AT A
RESTAURANT.
THESE PEOPLE -- THERE'S LEGAL
WAYS FOR REFUGEES TO BE ABLE TO
WORK IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE
SEEN SOME [ BLEEP ]
OKAY?
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO CALL OUT
BECAUSE THEIR BOYFRIEND BROKE UP
WITH THEM FOR THE THIRD TIME.
RESTAURANTS ARE STRUGGLING, JOB
OPENINGS NO ONE WILL TAKE.
BUT THE ENTIRE SYSTEM IS TOO
MESSED UP AND BACKLOGGED TO
ALLOW THAT.
LET SOME OF THESE PEOPLE WORK.
>> GUTFELD: YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
FIXING A PROCESS THAT MAKES
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO COME AND WORK
HERE REPLACE PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
WORKING HERE?
I WOULD VOTE FOR THAT.
BUT I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WOULD
WANT TO WORK IN A RESTAURANT
RIGHT NOW WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ACCUSED OF BEING RACIST OR
YOU ASK FOR A VACCINE CARD.
>> I DON'T KNOW, JESSICA CAN
KEEP WORKING ON HER FASHION BLOG
AND PEOPLE WHO WANT JOBS CAN
TAKE THE J